[Musique]
ok les gars on est venu pourquoi ou une
idée exacte maintenant activé ce truc
cette partie de vous que vous amener sur
le plateau je vous assure que ces gamins
ne sont pas prêts pour ce qu'il
s'apprête à voir
[Musique]
depuis la rue on nous appelait
bon les gars savent a semblé un peu
basique à certains ce qu'on a c'est 64
carré en deux pièces et que vous soyez
riche ou pauvre que vous fassiez l'école
de la vie ni de coupes à
l'échec tout le monde a sa chance
tournoi et tentent quelques jours il
nous faut quatre joueurs pourraient se
qualifier donc faut vraiment se poser la
question de si oui ou non on est
impliqué dans son pays si
vous perdez vous devez quitter la zone
en perdra pas
conseil d'administration des 400 $ des
ballons de foot mais quand il s'agit de
développement intellectuel de refuse de
me financer
et
[Musique]
gascogne sera issu de ce quartier ne
pourront jamais se payer ce concours
j'imagine qu'il s'offre au nec
[Musique]
laissez tomber mais c'est leurs parents
les laisser tomber le système scolaire
aussi mais c'est pas moi qui vais les
laisser tomber au caire
crois que ce moment précis elle plus
heureux que j'ai connus de tout étudié
ici de dante et d'avoir gagné un trophée
[Musique]
il ya maintenant un vrai potentiel
l'accès
[Musique]
attention le roi du bonhomme sur cette
voie pour vous et moi complètement